في انقاذ حياه عشرات او مئات او ممكن يكون
الاف الناس كيف بالعام هن عباره عن مجموعه
من الشباب المتدين لم يكن من غير متدينين
فدائيين يعني هون بتلعب مساله الايمان
دور كتير كبير
الامام بالله
والقضاء والقدر بيعرف انه يعني هو مؤمن
انه
يعني
اكثر من عامل يعني بس الايمان بيلعب دور
يعني بالموضوع يعني
هدول دورهن
المعلمين داخل المهجع المعلمين لهم دورين
اللي بدهم
يتعاقبوا سواء كان المعاقب مريض او كبير
بالعمر شيخ
الجسم ضعيف قد
يتاذى او قد يتوفى نتيجه التعذيب مثلا
200 كرباج يعني ليس يعني شيئا سهلا فهذول
مهمتهم هو
الحلول محل المعلم فالسجان ما بيعرف هو
علم مين قال له رئيس المهجى علمني فلان
علمني فلان بيعرف انه هو علم 12 شخص هذول
لازم الصبح يطلعوا
فبيطلعوا الفدائيين على الاغلب هل هي كانت
بين المسجونين او المعتقلين انفسهم
ايه طبعا يعني هو تبرع فداء تبرع من دون
ان يتدخل السجنون
ما له علاقه وما بيعرفوا فيها كان مشكله
يعني ما بيعرفوا
القوقعه التي دخلت فيها في داخل السجن
لانه كما تذكر في روايتك انك كنت بين
سندان القمع والظلم من قبل السجان ومطرقه
التشدد والتزمت من قبل المعتقلين زملائك
هل كان بها كروايه
حتى دراميه اضيف اليها الكثير من التوابل
اذا صح التعبير
بهدف الصنعه الروائيه او كانت في كلها او
معظمها على الاقل حقيقيه مئه بالمئه
يا سيدي ما فيها صنعه روائيه نهائيا لا
اكثر من هيك انا بدي اقول هلا بعد هالفتره
الزمنيه الطويله نحن واقعنا اسوا بعد وقال
سياسي بسوريا هيك وقعنا بين مطرقه النظام
وسندان التطرف